Here we go with domain number 4 which is obviously all about network security and we have
to start. Here we go with domain number 4 which is obviously all about network security and we
have to start right at the beginning and understand what a network actually is before we can
start talking about how we can protect and network and what it provides from a services perspective
because obviously networking today is very important in any organization and just like any other
valuable asset of the organization it's really there to allow the organization to achieve its
goals and objectives but when you think about the investment that companies make in networking it's
really important to be able to protect not only what it provides but all of the services and assets
and resources and data for example that really allows all kinds of people to be able to access
which is pretty important part of any organization to achieve network security. Now before we can talk
about what the network is and how to protect it let's really describe what networking and you know
how devices for example that are connected to each other actually talk to each other and so let's
start at the basics what is a network a network is at least two devices that are connected to each
other for the purpose of communicating and just like you and I communicate for example how people
communicate with each other certainly require some rules so for example when one person speaks the
other one listens but communication really happens because you know people are able to send and
receive messages so for example right now I'm sending messages to you through the spoken voice
but you have the ability to receive those messages understand them interpret them and act on them
that's how people communicate that's how you and I communicate it's the same requirement that
exists across a network so when you have devices that are connected to each other which essentially
is what a network is at least two devices communicating with each other they have to be able to send
and receive messages and not only do they send and receive messages but you have to have the
ability to interpret what those messages mean and then act on them to be able to ultimately communicate
and that's really what networking is all about so a network is a bunch of devices that are connected
to each other that really understand the same rules for example to be able to allow communications to
happen now the way that you and I communicate is by understanding rules for communications to happen
across a network we don't call them rules they are called protocols so the word protocol really
means the rules by which communications can happen between devices that are connected to each other
for the purpose of communicating and sharing information in fact if you look at the definition
of a protocol it might be something like this a standard set of rules that dictate for example how
devices communicate with each other but also how they send and receive messages but are also able
to interpret those messages and then act on them that's really what a protocol is